what up space fam goals in here from
anime out bro back at it again to
discuss the latest spoilers in the one
piece story and we got huge breaking
news about shanks our favorite red hair
yonko about what happens to green bull
to the dude that has been hyped up so
much recently and we catch up with luffy
and see some crazy news about him as
well so make sure to stay tuned for this
one there's a lot of interesting crazy
stuff to cover if you do enjoy these
spoiler reviews before the full
translated page reviews and want to keep
them coming you know what to do chill
the parking within and smash that like
button always be a smashing pirate king
rather than a passing orochi and youtube
will actually reward you with wano
fireworks true story test it out join
the nakama by subscribing and hitting
that notification bell to turn on all
notifications so you don't miss future
one-piece videos and updates including
the full review that's coming out later
this week with the full translated pages
of the manga chapter now without further
ado let's jump into it spoilers and all
so you may remember the 10 out of 10
chapter last week we left off with
shanks in wano deciding it's time to get
the one piece and sadly also deciding
that he won't see luffy this time thus
this was a development that may have led
to not seeing shanks again in the
following chapter but luckily he's still
in this one he's in this chapter and in
a big way too we learned about flame
emperor sabo and how the revolutionaries
were successful against fujitora and
greenville last chapter yamato also got
a good hit on green bull and even
greenville said it hurt however momo
told yamato to stay out of it and that
brings us to the latest chapter called
new era in other words it's a big one
and seems to be marking the end of wano
and the beginning of something new and
that will make even more sense when we
get to the end of the chapter we're told
momo stopped yamato from interfering
because he wants to save wano alone as
that's his duty so it's pretty much what
we assumed he wanted to handle it and
the fact that yamato might be leaving
with the straw hat soon makes it all the
more necessary for momo to be able to
handle these issues himself since yamato
won't presumably be here for much longer
despite having the guardian deity of
wanofruit we then jump into momo vs
green bulb which is sort of hilarious
last time momo was supposed to launch a
bowl of breath but nothing came out he
hasn't been an impressive fighter so far
while greenball was introduced as very
op although the most recent chapters
including this one have definitely done
a lot to tame the hype expectations for
him think about it at first it seemed
like he effortlessly dealt with king
queen we knew they were injured but we
didn't know how much they've recovered
so it could have potentially been a very
impressive feat but since then we
learned the revolution commander
succeeded against him in fujitora and
that yamato could hurt him sure you
might say it's not a serious injury but
still it definitely gives us a different
impression than the idea of him
effortlessly beating king and queen at
the same time along with everyone else
this chapter continues in the hype
taming tradition of recent chapters
we're told that momo with a single bowl
of breath heavily injures green bull now
we'll see how heavy this injury actually
is when the full translated pages come
out but i'm sure it's not gonna be
anything that keeps greenville down he
may just be a dude who unlike zorro
likes to express how much stuff hurt
even if he can take a lot of damage and
can dish out even more potentially
nevertheless getting heavily hurt by
momo does make him seem like less of a
threat when he was just fully introduced
recently some people were saying he
could potentially take down the straw
hats and here he is having trouble with
yamato and momo and you definitely can't
deny that they're slowing him down here
which is a feat in and of itself that
being said though full props to momo for
becoming the beast he was meant to
become and sooner than expected actually
being able to launch painful bowl of
breath attacks goes a long way in making
him a better defender of wano then as if
admiral greenbelt didn't look weak
enough already we're told he gives up
after sensing shanks's conqueror's
hockey ambition and realizing that the
red hair pirates are near now this is
going to be a very hyped part of the
chapter this hadron who felt like he
could walk in and defeat the man who
beat kaido the so-called strongest
creature in the world and all of his
allies just gives up when he gets a
whiff of shanks's hockey like it's crazy
and hilarious to think about i've been
saying this lately including in my
hour-long shanks video link in the
description that shanks is the strongest
yonko at least until blackbeard steps up
big time and shows us something new that
we haven't seen yet and oda seems to
confirm that right here by having green
bull turn tail and run and obviously we
don't have the full context of him
giving up and what he does next because
this isn't the full chapter it's just
spoilers but that's kind of the fun of
these spoiler videos i love talking
about them when we know less information
and then comparing them to what actually
happens in the chapter it's actually
been really fun doing that anyways the
idea of people stopping or running from
shanks is nothing new it actually
reminds us of marine ford where he
stopped that war but it's still crazy
how much shanks could completely change
green bull's plan of action in this case
shanks didn't even say anything as far
as we can see from these spoilers green
bull just doesn't even want to take the
chance of running into him or at least
that's what it seems like now is green
bull still strong yes of course there's
no way he's not and i don't think him
being hurt by yamato and momo is
representative of his power but clearly
this suggests that shanks is stronger
and greenbold wants none of it and to be
fair to greenball we're told he realizes
the red hair pirates are near so it's
shanks's whole crew he has to consider
and not just shanks one question is
though why did shanks let out the
conquerors haki we all suspect i think
that at least right now shanks has the
strongest conquerors haki of all yonko
it was heavily implied when he went
aboard whitebeard's ship pre-time skip
and chances are it's gotten even
stronger since however at that point it
was suggested that he was letting it out
accidentally because he was uneasy being
on an enemy ship so why did he let it
out this time at wano when seemingly he
was under no threat okay so future goes
in here and we got more information
about the chapter so here are the ones
relating to this crazy shanks
development so we're told suddenly black
lightning can be seen in the distance
green bull feels something is paralyzing
him and he screams in pain he screams
out and says wait wait that's
conqueror's hockey who are you what red
hair pirates and they're this close end
quote the red hair pirates ship is still
in the sea near wano some of their
members ask shanks to stop or all the
rookies are going to faint so shang says
i won't say you're despicable but a
marine targeting those new leaves that
just changed pirate history i think is
tasteless so here shanks is talking with
green bull he's saying stuff to him but
clearly they're not close together so
either greenville is just getting his
emotion that shanks descending through
his conqueror's hockey or shanks is
somehow sending him his thoughts but i
feel like the emotions is more plausible
as shanks is saying this we can see some
of his memories together with luffy and
we also see a silhouette that seems to
be utta aka shanks's daughter from the
new upcoming movie then we see a
close-up panel of shanks he's very angry
shank says are you afraid of the coming
new era green bull returns to his normal
form and says he has no intention of
fighting shanks and his crew at least
not now he finally decides to leave so
this is big for a few reasons including
the fact that now we know that yes this
wasn't shanks just accidentally letting
out conquerors hockey it's because he
purposely knew greenville was there and
he wanted to scare him off and he
succeeded it's it's crazy how strong and
powerful this dude is and how much sway
he has over others including people as
strong as marine admirals but wow shanks
just keeps delivering and adding to his
legendariness with each chapter he's
present in i can't overstate how well
oda's done with him and building hype
around his character it's pretty much
the reason he probably can't have luffy
and shanks team up right now because
shanks is just too broken now
temporarily we cut to the land
underneath wano don't worry we will
return to shanks and luffy even but
first down to the land underneath wano
we're told sukiyaki takes robert and law
to the depths where the road poneglyph
is hidden in the old wano country again
that's hype because these road
poneglyphs lead to the one piece we are
clearly very close with one piece coming
into focus with shanks and now with the
road poneglyph he goes on to explain how
the current wano was built we'll surely
get more information about this in the
chapter but for now we're told wanna was
a bigger island which became small
because of the rising sea level there is
even more lore from the poneglyph and
robin's conversation with sukiyaki which
we'll discuss when the full chapter
comes out and we have it all but for now
let's stick to the hypest of revelations
we're told the straw hats continue their
festive celebration but then we're told
that luffy and kid
sense shanks's hockey going throughout
wano wow this is big and i love the fact
that kid is included here because of his
history with shanks i look forward so
much to seeing how he'll react in
particular but yeah we'll actually get
to see luffy reacting to shanks being in
wano and it won't be a thing where he
just completely missed him which i'm
relieved about now future goes in here
with more manga updates so the way luffy
sensed shanks didn't go down as i
expected he seems less certain that
shanks was there jinbei says but that
hockey has been impressive luffy
responds i know what was that at the end
of the chapter we're told luffy smiles
while the red hair pirates ship is
moving away from wano and then luffy
says somehow a familiar face popped in
my mind so in these more complete
spoilers luffy doesn't actually as i
hoped know for sure it was shanks or at
least that's what it seems like it seems
like he just kind of sensed the haki and
then saw a picture of shanks but isn't
sure that it was actually him besides
that kid is not mentioned here as saying
anything so so we'll have to see when we
get the full translated pages exactly
what's going on but at the very least at
least luffy and shanks made some kind of
contact can't wait to find out more
about the specifics but again it really
seems like shanks is being hyped up by
oda as the strongest here someone whose
vicinity alone can scare off an admiral
an admiral who'd been hyped up like
crazy just a few chapters ago but yeah
that is it for these crazy spoilers
shanks has not left us yet and his
immense hockey has made his presence
known to the important parties what will
luffy do i mean it would be awesome if
he chased after him but i'm guessing
that's not what's gonna happen still
shanks's presence alone has just changed
the immediate fates of all of these
characters and of course if you do enjoy
these spoiler reviews before the full
translator page reviews come out and
want to keep them coming you know what
to do chill parking within and smash
that like button with no mercy always be
a smashing power king rather than a
passing orochi and youtube will reward
you with wano fireworks of all things
like i said true story you can test it
out join the not come up by subscribing
and hitting that notification bell so
you don't miss the full review later in
the week or other one piece videos and
updates while you wait for the full
review to drop feel free to check out my
huge and growing one piece playlist that
includes videos on the yonko admirals
warlords and much more link to that is
in the description on screen right now
along with my hour-long shanks video
where you can relive all the other epic
stuff shanks did from birth to now drop
a hashtag running bull if you're a real
one and made it all the way to the end
thank you so much i appreciate you and
until next time see you space cowboys